cuáles son las vejaciones más señaladas
y preocupantes y cuál es el contexto de
estas violaciones sistemáticas cometidas
por china
buenas noches andrés cómo estás
bueno en realidad las denuncias por
violaciones a derechos humanos tienen
varios años en la región de cienciano y
no solamente de parte de la población
sino también de parte de diferentes
países y ongs y activistas derechos
humanos y entre las principales
violaciones se mencionan la construcción
de estancos e instituciones de
reeducación
buscando justamente
[Música]
y reencaminar
particularmente biológicamente a esta
minoría musulmana
campos de trabajos forzados diferentes
tipos de abusos
encarcelamientos sin justificación y
persecución generalizada de la población
opositora a la el partido central ahora
qué precedente marca este informe
después de las denuncias que hemos
venido escuchando sobre los abusos
contra la población uigur tiene el texto
la capacidad para generar un efecto de
protección para estos ciudadanos
bueno es una pregunta difícil de
responder pero
este que tenerlo en el contexto de que
china es la segunda potencia económica
global y una de las principales
potencias a nivel
armamentístico nuclear y científico que
en diferentes y tecnológicos por
supuesto entonces la fuerza que pueda
tener este documento está muy en
relación con justamente el poder
relativo de china
y la capacidad y la posibilidad de los
países de hacer cumplir lo que se busque
implementar o castigar con el texto más
allá de que el texto de naciones unidad
no plantea firmemente una denuncia de
por ejemplo genocidio
[Música]
y tampoco plantea
la toma de medidas de respuesta
d
castigo
al gobierno chino por esta violación
entonces creo que
difícilmente
puede encaminar la situación aunque sí
es una reivindicación de los reclamos de
esta población